hello my name is jeff uh goldblum
goldblum
and um
i'm i'm reading from some of the first
oh yes first thing i did it first name
last name uh
empty something
yeah and then pause here comes
that's enough of that
and i feel
and then it says here uh parenthesis
however i feel well
[Laughter]
madness
madness madness hey that's the last line
of what movie this is here last line of
movie madness
madness
tell me the book oh my god i know that
movie i know that is it older movie uh
yes
wait a minute
i could give you a clue oh godness wait
a minute
is it
hold it madness is it um uh apocalypse
now no
ah no that's the horror
you're close though yeah and it has a
similar
oh wait it's the last family ties
no it does it ends with madness
i love that this is the introduction
we have to wrap up what this movie is
and then do the name thing all is one
giant piece we're still rolling yeah
we're still rolling but wait wait give
it and this has been real you can't use
this as no we can but give us a hint on
that movie
uh okay i'll give you a hint um a lesser
cast member jack hawkins probably don't
even know who they are oh mike what kind
of clue is that okay a ceramic mug
features in a breakfast scene there's a
clue for you no jack hawkins there are
those who know very well jack hoggins
again and already know this movie i'll
give you the uh a giveaway clue
uh bill holden william holden oh uh
stalag17 no good no pretty good guess
that's a kind of a war picture he does
not deliver the last line by the way oh
the glitch over the river flies
over the river that was my lap just as
he blows up the bridge yes exactly now
all together let's whistle the song that
is right
ready that's the wrong one
okay
that's it
i can't whistle and i don't know that
you cannot whistle i can't whistle and
is that true i i don't have never seen
when i was a kid in camp we used to they
taught us these old songs from the 50s
as we trudged up the appalachian
mountains and we had to sing
comet it makes your teeth turn green
it tastes like vaseline comet make you
vomit so drink your comet and vomit
today
again
and we would do it again and i climbed
the presidential mountain range of
singing that song not knowing what it
was how it why why just because and then
you learned later that was from that
movie yeah that's funny that's funny hey
do you know this saw you reminded me of
the uh song we're on the upward trail
we're on the upward trail singing
singing everybody's singing as we go
that would have been a more legit
version of the marching song uh yes i
suppose now where does that song come
from because you've confused us once
again and also how do you feel about
being conan o'brien
hi my name is
my name is jeff goldblum and i feel like
being here with you now as if
i'm revealing myself to myself and
and
i feel utterly drenched and purged
okay
now that's from a kind of an homage to a
movie line also that's not my
originality and my uh
turn my podcast into a kooky trivia i
love it